une démonstration de force un message
d'unité pour daniasmith sa victoire la
nouvelle chèvre voulait rapidement
réunir son cocus et établir une cohésion
que longtemps manqué dans le parti et
ouais
dans le caucus la première impression
lessive par la nouvelle chef semble
réussir même si certains reconnaissent
qu'il y aura du travail à faire
la course à la succession de Jason Kenny
aurait été crimonieuse arrivée deuxième
travesti se fait aujourd'hui bon joueur
big time
veut rétablir les ponts au sein de son
parti le ton est différent avec le
gouvernement fédéral la prochaine
première ministre Albertine métier qu'il
fera de sa loi sur la souveraineté sa
priorité déjà tendue les relations avec
Ottawa pourraient encore s'assombrir
sont possibles pour livrer concrètement
pour les priorités des Albertins que ce
soit à lutter contre les hausses du coup
de la vie que ce soit de la création de
bons emplois
le position n'a pas tardé à réagir au
couronnement de Daniel Smith un peu plus
de 6 mois des prochaines élections la
bataille est lancée et la chef du LPD a
déjà choisi la loi sur la souveraineté
comme cible et
Justin
a gagné cette course à la direction en
courtisant la base la plus militante de
la droite albertaine située surtout en
milieu rural elle doit maintenant
prouver qu'elle peut diriger un parti
gouverner une province pour tous les
Albertins cette course au leadership a
été difficile mais pour Daniel Smith le
plus dur est peut-être encore à venir
ici Mathieu Gohier Radio-Canada Calgary